about the coefficient of x cubed in
such-and-such in touch okay simple idea
is it do you need Hana care familiar
wait is that so all we have to do key
really is Meishan we understand how
binomial coefficients work just on their
own and then understand how they
interact with these guys okay
so we're gonna start from here about as
simple as you can get and then we'll go
all the way now I am actually going to
because this is sufficiently simple okay
I have actually need to write more or
less the entire expansion that we've got
here because it will be helpful for when
we do these next questions okay
I'm not going to write one for 641 even
though I could because if I made this
question 48 like to power 40 then you
can't answer it with one four six point
one you're gonna have ridiculous numbers
you're gonna have to rely on this
technique okay so what are the
coefficients alright we're on the fourth
row of Pascal's triangle so the first
term should be four C naught right now
I've got the X up the front so I tend to
write it in decreasing order of powers
of X but you don't have to but we tend
to so of course the highest power here
will be X to the 4
that's my pattern right so now I go to
the next coefficient and then my power
drops down I go to the next coefficient
there my power goes down now I could
keep going but you can see I don't need
to I don't need to keep going anymore
right because all these terms after this
I'll have all my terms after this will
be irrelevant to answering this question
do you see that like I'm never gonna get
an x cubed back that's it right there
there's no more execute terms that are
going to appear okay so therefore I have
my answer I guess now it's forcing one
he's chucking your calculator if it was
40 to the power of 40 right you skir now
think for a second if I'm on the
fortieth row okay then this term is
going to be not X to the four it would
be X to the 40 do you agree with that
it's the first one so I have to go all
the way down to here until like
soon the x-cubed her now therefore what
will that coefficient at the front be
we'll do the easy part first it'll be 40
because I'm at a 40th row see something
what will the something be now look at
your pattern see look at your patterns
for instance you can see this number
doesn't change right 4 C 4 C 4 C etc the
numbers that do change this guy right
see what and coefficient right I've got
go ahead for then I get one at 3 then I
get to - do you see the pattern yet so
this number here and the power should
add up to whatever row I'm on in this
particular table you see that my next
one would be for C 1 1 and it'll be
sorry now it's in the back 43 I'm going
across and X to the 1 so there's a dark
to whichever roll I'm on what roll my
own I'm on route 40 so I should have 37
here right which will be some enormous
number because there are many ways to
choose 37 objects out of 40 so you
wouldn't get for you but you can see the
strength of doing this rather than
writing 1 4 6 4 1 is that it generalizes
it's a more versatile approach do you
understand that
ok now what's different here what's
different here I've purposely chosen the
same power so you can see the idea from
above but what's different
so these coefficients are put the minted
read for see not foreseen 1/4 C - all
the same all the same because I am still
in the same row of Pascal's triangle so
I still have a 4 C naught and I'll still
have a for C 1 and I'll still have a 4 C
2 but what I x is going to be a little
more complicated because these guys are
more complicated they're these guys for
starters how I had X to the 4 here right
that's because it's X to the 4 I don't
have actually I
to X right and the two comes along for
the ride okay so it's 2x if the whole
thing gets raised to the power of 4 plus
okay now I'm gonna need some more space
young shove my 42 when I go to the next
term two things happen number one this
2x to the for you see how he drops down
a power so you'll be 2x to the three you
see that but at the same time and it's
disguised in the first question because
1 to the power anything is still 1 as
this guy decreases in power
this guy increases in power in fact
right here there's a 3/3 or hiding bunch
should run because the three of the
noise 1 that means that here as I
increase is going to be a 3 that one
there okay I'll do the next one just so
I establish the pattern for C 2 it's
going to be 2 to the X square
yeah these people let me show the Plus
these knives okay so you can see there
are three components to each term in my
expansion right number one there's just
the binary coefficients themselves
number two there's the first bit of
whatever power I have that and then
there's the I picked up an example
here's the first bit second term is the
third right which comes from the other
term in the binomial binomial them up to
okay so now just have you look at this
what if it what's the term I'm
interested in just like in part one
just like in part one I don't need to go
any further right I'm not going to get
there's an X to the four there's the X
cubed there's next since you I'm not
going to get any more X cube trips
coming out of this right so I simply
want to grab this guy now what's the
coefficient it's bit more complicated to
just four see what isn't it right I do
have four see one but what else has come
on to the right there's the two cubed
which is 8 and then there's the three so
that's 24 and fortunate one is four so
that looks like
to me so 96 would be the coefficient of
x cubed in this guy there'd be 96 X
cubed and some other other stuff which I
don't really
okay now we're prepared for this guy now
this is more difficult and I like these
other ones we can have to be a bit more
careful before we just stop writing up
to us let's give this a go you're going
to need a wide page here right here I'm
going to write let's see I'm on the
second room second right so I'm going to
get to see what times what x squared
very good
plus 2 C 1 X plus 2 sorry to see to that
- should be look to see - on time
because it's time 1 so there is my
expansion of this guy there's that
expansion okay now we have a look at
this next part let's give this guy I'm
on the third row so I'm gonna go 3 C
naught okay the first term will not be 2
X to the 4 because my power is drop down
you seen that okay in fact it will be 2
X cube that's my first board okay how
many other terms I've done here I've got
a 3 but I didn't have any of those it's
3 than board so I can move on to the
next one 3 C 1 okay and I'm gonna have 2
X 4 squared and then I get 1/3 hanging
on for the ride
3 2 1 okay then I'm always for you some
halfway there I'm gonna get 3 C - how
many - X's do I have just the one but I
have an extra 3 and then use comes my
last term how many 2 X's do I have none
of them
- nice it had one but as three of these
guys 3 okay and that expands our second
binomial this monstrous thing yup that's
the worst place ever
okay Natha have a look at this now
because we have a binomial times another
binomial this is dramatically increased
the difficulty and complexity
what we're looking at right because for
instance have a look at these cuts there
are no X cubed terms here there are none
okay but if I take for instance this guy
right and I'm multiplying it by a
particular term in the second expansion
I will get an X cubed do you see that
which terms am I going to match up this
is x squared so I want an X to the one
from over here you see that and where is
it it's there it is okay so I'm going to
multiply those two together and that
will give me the next cuter that's not
the only time it happens it happens
again he's an X term you call up I want
to pair it with an x squared term in the
other expansion namely
this guy right again lastly hope I got
enough clothes I do he's a constant no
Exodus when if I pair him with an X
cubed term then again you can see by the
way the colors may lead you the colors
help you can as well see there's this
symmetry happening do you see that
you're not going to miss any chance
because you're like fan fan man and you
can also see why this one term hanging
over there that doesn't get used why is
that because it's a it's a constant what
you would have to match with is an X
cubed term which doesn't exist
okay so I've accounted for all these
I've done okay now all I need to do is
just assemble the answer okay so I was
going to keep it color coded as fast as
I can
right in fact the position I'll leave
that off because all I want is I don't
need any excuse
okay I just want the coefficients out of
each one okay so let's have a look at
this black one what am I gonna get from
here I get to see naught and then from
here careful I've got 3 c2 well so I got
p6 I've got a 2 and I have a 3 squared
is that okay times two times three
squared you're right with that
just the coffee's no need to worry about
the excellence okay let's have a look
who's next guy over here I've got I've
got a to see one should be able start to
take advantage of a patent right then
I've got here my claim I've got three
see one how many twos oh my god I've got
a to square doughnut and I've got a
single three and then last one here we
go
out of these red terms I'm getting
that's - see - there's three C naught
and how many twos do I have I have two
cubed which is 8 I've got three of them
it's okay
alright so now that's it I mean I've got
to evaluate them obviously but I've got
all the hard work I had expanded these
first two binomials which gives you this
royal mess but if you take your time
with it be logical use some colors to
help you out you can see the bits that
need to match up and then you get your
numbers out of the end so we just
quickly evaluate it we go to C naught is
1/3 C 2 will be 3 times 2 times 9 is 18
plus 2 C 1 is going to be 2/3 C 1 is
going to be 3 times 4 times 3 is 12
- C 2 is 1/3 C naught is 1 and okay we
yeah so this is what 58 which sure
enough gives us